[Music]
Nick Cannon is leaving America's Got
Talent after eight seasons I truly feel
like it's the the next stage in my life
36 year old posted a lengthy statement
to Facebook on Monday after NBC
allegedly threatened to fire him over a
racial joke he made in a new comedy
special on Showtime quote my soul won't
allow me to be in business with
corporations that attempt to frown on
freedom of speech and I wish AGG and NBC
the best in its upcoming season but I
cannot see myself returning
entertainment is outstanding but I truly
want to utilize my voice Nick also says
that it's never been about the money for
him but what is hard is walking away
from the fans of the show quote this
hurts tremendously he ended his Facebook
post for the quote from dr. Martin
Luther King our lives begin to end the
day we become silent about the things
that matter the thing is you got to live
life in and you know take hardships and
things like that as as it hurtles were
made to jump over
you